and what is almost an unprecedented move
president Trump invited lawmakers to the
White House today and peel back the
curtains by actually allowing TV cameras
into the room to capture their debate on
immigration now most of you I'm sure
unable to watch this play out in full so
we're gonna play large portions for you
tonight in case you missed it now the
president started off the discussion by
telling members of Congress that border
security has to come first in any deal
yes and we want the wall
take a look we're here today to advance
bipartisan immigration reform that
serves the needs of the American
families workers and taxpayers its daca
we've been talking about doctor for a
long time I've been hearing about it for
years long before I decided to go into
this particular line of work and maybe
we can do something we have a lot of
good people in this room a lot of people
that have a great spirit for taking care
of people we represent we all represent
for that reason any legislation on daca
we feel at least a strong part of the
school fields has to accomplish three
vital goals and chairman Goodlatte will
be submitting a bill over the next two
to three days that will cover many of
these things and obviously that will if
it gets passed it'll go to the Senate
and they can negotiate and we'll see how
it all turns out but I feel having the
Democrats in with us is absolutely vital
because this should be a bipartisan bill
it should be a bill of love truly should
be a bill of love and we can do that but
it also has to be a bill where we're
able to secure our border drugs are
pouring into our country at a record
pace a lot of people are coming in that
we can't have we've greatly stiffened as
you know and fewer people are trying to
have it
have tremendous numbers of people and
drugs pouring into our country so in
order to secure it we need a wall we
need closing enforcement we have to
close enforcement loopholes give
immigration officers and these are
tremendous people the border security
agents the ice agents we have to give
them the equipment they need we have to
close loopholes and this really does
include a very strong amount of
different things for border security I
think everybody in the room would agree
to that I think that we it's a question
of amounts but I think everyone agrees
we have to have border security I don't
think it'd be anybody that says no
second it has to be a bill to end chain
migration chain migration is bringing in
many many people with one and often it
doesn't work out very well those many
people are not doing us right and I
think a lot of people in the room I'm
not sure I can speak for everybody but a
lot of the people in this room want to
see chain migration ended and we have a
recent case along the West Side Highway
having to do with chain migration where
a man ran over killed eight people and
many people injured badly loss of arms
loss of legs horrible thing happened and
then you look at the chain and all the
people that came in because of him
terrible situation and the or the others
canceled a lottery program they call it
Visa Lottery I just call it a lottery
where countries come in and they put
names in a hopper and they're not giving
you their best names common sense means
they're not giving you their best names
they're giving you people that they
don't want now as you watch this tonight
remember this is the same president that
the media and every Democrat has been
telling you for days and weeks and in
some cases months is absolutely crazy no
he was very engaged he was totally in
charge and being transparent extremely
patient and common-sense solutions were
being offered he was giving you the
American people a rare glimpse into a
historic process on the important issue
of immigration reform and just a few
hours ago while the president tweeted
as I made very clear today our country
needs the security of the wall on the
southern border which must be a part of
any doc approval president obviously now
refusing to back down on building the
border wall I've been saying this for
months and years in order for the GOP to
be successful you guys want to win the
midterm elections build two or three
hundred miles of the border wall go down
there and cut your commercials promise
made promise kept
voters happy the American people need to
see tangible results and progress being
made on this key promise is key for
November this has to be fun the wall
build the wall first because it's always
like oh you get the tax increase you
never get the spending cuts they promise
you always get the consideration the
amnesty whatever it happens to be the
wall never gets built we have been down
this road we've seen this rodeo before
you're Republicans you want to win in
November Europe for election not Donald
Trump put the American people put their
security first and show them that by
November you're keeping your promises
just smart good for the country good
politics after the president's remarks
Democrats they quickly move to their
debate all they care about is avinasi
daca amnesty and daca take a look
Democrats are for security at the
borders I want to state that emphatic ly
there's not a Democrat that is not for
having security borders there are
obviously differences however mr.
president on how you effect that you
just indicated that yourself and you
indicated this would be a first step and
then we continue to talk as we're
talking today about how we best secure
the border there are differences of
opinion in within your party within our
party so I would urge that we move
forward on
protecting the daka protected
individuals young young people young
adults as you pointed out in one of your
statements who are productive parts of
our community that we protect them and
get that done and then because I think
everybody around the table as you
pointed out is for security and then the
issue is going to be how do we best
effect that border security so I would
our just to move as Senator Durbin has
urged us move on the doctor students as
a matter of fact the Speaker I think
today but maybe yesterday said we need
to solve the daca issue and we need to
solve it in a way that is permanent not
temporary and I grooving them on that
issue and interestingly when you say
that President Obama when he signed the
executive order actually said he doesn't
have the right to do this and so you do
have to go through Congress and you do
have to make it friendly whether he does
whether he doesn't let's assume he
doesn't you said it and that was a
temporary stopgap I don't think we want
that I think we want to have a permanent
solution to this and I think everybody
in this room feels that way very
strongly what happened mr. president I
think is that the Senate passed a
comprehensive immigration bill as you
know we did not consider it in the house
so we didn't reach those issues very
frankly on border security mr. McCaul
the chairman of the committee reported
out a unanimous security solution which
which we then included in the bill that
we filed on comprehensive immigration
reform so I think we can reach agreement
well I also think that after we do daca
and I really believe we should be able
to be successful I really think we
should look in terms of your permanent
solution and
the whole situation with immigration I
think a lot of people in this room would
agree to that also but we'll do it in
steps and most people agree with that I
think they will do the steps even you
say let's do this and then we go Phase
two Kevin what would you like to say
well first I want to thank you for
bringing everybody together you got the
Senate you got the house you got both
parties and I like the exchange of ideas
and I think everybody has a point here
the one thing I don't want to have
happen here is what I saw in the past
there were former bills that were passed
on border security years ago that never
got finished their immigration bills
passed that were right back at the table
with the same problem let's make a
commitment to each one the most
importantly to the American people then
when we get done and come to an
agreement they were not back at this
problem three four years ago
that's why yes we've got to do got that
I agree with you 100% but if we do not
do something with the security if we do
not do something with the chain
migration we are fooling each other that
we solve the problem you know how
difficult this issue is so let's
collectively we're here at the table
together I'll be the first one to tell
you we're all gonna have to give a
little and I'll be the first one willing
to but let's solve the problem but let's
not tell the American public at the end
that it solved what it's not great
points by Kevin McCarthy here are some
of the other big moments from today's
immigration debate take a look at this
the country is doing well in so many
ways but there's such divisive this
division and I really believe we can
solve that I think this system is a very
bad system in terms of getting together
and I'm gonna leave it up to you but I
really believe you can do something to
bring it together
ten years I don't think I've seen a
better chance to get it done I did not
do right now because if you John's right
I'm not gonna support a bill if you
don't support it
I've had my head beat out a bunch I'm
still standing I'm Lindsey Graham misty
Lindsey Gomes you named every name you
want to give to me it's been assigned to
me and I'm still standing the people of
South Carolina want a result how could I
get elected I've been for a pathway to
citizenship for 11 million people
because I have no animosity toward them
I don't want Cruz I don't want that
hombres I want to get a merit-based
immigration system to make sure we can
succeed in the 21st century I'm willing
to be more than fair to the 11 million I
just don't want to do this every 20
years he's taking a very big hit in the
last year what's happening I mean you
look at these killers whether you like
or not we're looking at these killers
and then you see 18 people came in 22
people came in 30 people came in with
this one person that just killed a lot
of people I really don't believe there
are a lot of Democrats saying that would
be supporting chain migration anymore
should we have the Homeland Security
this justice Cummings on border security
I just want to try to make sure we're
all linking the reason that border
security is so important to have as part
of this discussion is that it doesn't
solve the problem if we can apprehend
people but we can't remove them so we
need the wall system which is some
physical infrastructure as the the
president described personnel and
technology but we have to close those
legal legal loopholes because the effect
of that is this incredible call up from
Central America that just continues to
exacerbate the problem so border
security has to be part of this where we
will be here again in three four five
years again maybe unfortunately sooner I
just want to emphasize what secretary
Nielsen said it is so important they
understand when you talk about Morris
if you apprehend somebody at the border
but then you cannot send them back
outside the United States even though
they're unlawfully present in the United
States you have not solved this problem
because they're then released into the
interior of the country and the problem
persists and that sends a message back
to wherever they've come from they come
do it the other thing that we got to
look at the wall itself mr. president
you talk to your Border Patrol chief or
the former border patrol Chiefs I've
asked them how much time does a wall by
you they'll say a couple minutes or a
few seconds and this is our own Border
Patrol chiefs that I've said that all
you have to do is ask Israel what
happened with appropriations your chief
was there and the former Chiefs have all
said that now the other thing is mr.
president if you look at where the walls
are at right now this is where the
activity is where the walls are at right
now have massive miles of area where
people are pouring through them right
now one of the good things because of
our rhetoric or because of the perceived
you know my perceived attitude fewer
people are trying to come through that's
a great thing and that therefore I mean
our numbers have been fantastic maybe
for all the right way sir let me just
finish my thought the I want to ask you
that we're playing you saw the game last
time it's a good game we're playing
defense on the one-yard line call the US
border we spent over 18 billion dollars
a year on the border if we think about
playing defense on the 20-yard line if
you look at what Mexico has done
they stopped thousands of people on the
southern border with Guatemala we are
be looking at and what do we stop them
we stopped him you know why Mexico told
me the president told me everybody tells
me not as many people are coming through
their southern border because they don't
think they'd get through our southern
border and therefore they don't come
that's what happened with Mexico we did
Mexico a tremendous favor we actually
put appropriation to help with the
southern the point is I know we always
give everybody every other nation gets
money but ours but we're always looking
for money but we give the money to other
than the last one that we have this
stuff is instead of playing defense on
the wanting outline if you look this is
your material we know where the stash
houses are at we know where the hotels
are and we know whether our across the
river and we're going here my watch
stopped white played defense on the
1-yard I'm going after him like never
before with our increased focus on daca
we can work on the other things
separately on sensible water security
listen to the folks that are from the
border and if you folks are gonna have
video one of course your folks are gonna
have to come up with the solution and if
you do I'm gonna sign that solution if
we have a lot of smart people in this
room really smart beep we have a lot of
people that are good people big hearts
they want to get it done I think almost
everybody I can think of one or two I
don't particularly like but that's okay
I think everybody
everybody wants I'm trying to figure
everybody wants a solution you wanted it
I mean it's wonderful I'd love not to
build the wall but you need the wall you
can I will tell you this the ice
officers and the Border Patrol agents I
had them just recently up in Korea they
say if you don't have the wall you know
in certain areas obviously that aren't
protected by nature if you don't have
the wall you cannot have security just
get it happen it doesn't work you don't
have the wall you'll never have security
also the DHS secretary Nielsen made some
great points as you saw in that exchange
and as we saw today the President and
even some Republicans are saying the
border wall has to come first
it has to and then Congress can talk
about other things to me that's the
right answer if you build the wall
expeditiously and fully fund it you can
move forward you can have your
discussions chain migration also must go
away a lottery system we've learned in
the last year must go away and when it
comes to the Democrats they are massive
hypocrites and they're being exposed and
nothing but political opportunists on
the issue of immigration I doubt anyone
else in the media is about to show you
these massive flip-flops take a look I
voted numerous times when I was a
senator to spend money to build a a
barrier to try to prevent illegal
immigrants from coming in and I do think
you have to control your borders where
it was necessary we did support some
fencing where it was necessary
we did add Border Patrol agents we have
done what by any fair estimate would
have to conclude is a good job quote
securing the border people who enter the
United States without our permission are
illegal aliens and illegal aliens should
not be treated the same as people who
entered the US legally the American
people will never accept immigration
reform unless they truly believe that
their government is committed to ending
future illegal immigration the
president's decision to end daca was
heartless and it was brainless
if this order stands hundreds hundreds
of thousands of families will be ripped
apart tens of thousands of American
businesses will lose hard-working
employees those who enter our country
legally and those who employ them
disrespect the rule of law and because
we live in an age where terrorists are
challenging our borders we cannot allow
people to pour into the u.s. undetected
undocumented and unchecked if there are
disruptions in these countries if
there's conflict if there's bad
governance if there's war if there's
poverty in this new world that we live
in we can't isolate ourselves we can't
hide behind the wall it shows how far
left now this Democratic Party is moved
by the way anyone else going to point
out the hypocrisy I guess now that it's
politically expedient for the Democratic
Party and now opposing the policies they
were passionately supporting in masse
now foxnews.com has a great article up
today showcasing the Democrats blatant
hypocrisy on immigration here's the
headline Dems changed tune on border
wall after backing barrier under Obama
and the reporting points out that five
years ago under Barack Obama the entire
Democratic caucus voted to build 700
miles of fencing along the southern
border it's the same area the president
Trump's proposed border wall would cover
they didn't get the job done and it
doesn't end there the bills Democrats
supported which was called the economic
opportunity and immigration
Modernization Act also included 40
billion dollars over a decade to
strengthen border security measures and
also call the doubling the number called
for doubling the number of border agents
to be hired would have been a good idea
here's what this tells us Democratic
Party and their opposition or President
Trump is asking for it's nothing but a
total farce it's about playing politics
identity politics it has nothing to do
with the facts and reality about what is
going on at the border look I have
personally been reporting from the
border at least a dozen times
horseback all-terrain vehicle
I've been out there in helicopters and
boats have done it all all of it
I've seen gang members being arrested a
warehouse the biggest one you've ever
seen floor-to-ceiling drugs that were
confiscated I've been in a drug
smuggling tunnel and much more the
problems down there are real human
trafficking drug trafficking Democrats
don't want to address these issues
because they'd rather try and now score
cheap political points